la pauvreté pour pouvoir l'éradiquer ils
font parler et encore en parler la
bibliothèque départementale avec la
banque alimentaire des mascareignes
présente une exposition sur ce thème
composé de plusieurs tableaux liés à
cette problématique dans le monde
phrase que j'ai cités tout à l'heure de
dindonneau me disais que nous ne sommes
pas constitué de nos choix mais
tout autant de tu veux nous ne faisons
pas
cézanne ou renoncement et c'est vrai et
ça nous a rappelé le discours de vie
dans l'eau parce que quand on dit que
peur des gens en difficulté on connaît
ou sais ce que c'est que la pauvreté et
on connaît ce discours l'assemblée
nationale et c'est aussi un petit peu
par des données en vigueur on a le film
c'est comme ça qu'on a inventé le fil à
une vision proposée aux jeunes sur
l'intolérable situation de pauvreté qui
règne dans le monde et même à côté de
nous pour la présidente du conseil
départemental des jeunes il est
important de mener des actions de
sensibilisation pense que oui déjà dans
dans la vie courante quand on passe à
côté de quelqu'un qui n'a pas forcément
les groupes les moyens ne va passer deux
nuits à côté de lui derrière avec 1
ajoutant l'idée franchement ressouder
les liens entre entre tous les
réunionnais c'est important par ailleurs
le conseil départemental des jeunes
mènent des actions avec les sdf
donc c'est c'est bientôt on va les voir
partager une après midi avec eux en
déjeuner et je crois que c'est vraiment
important que nous les jeunes on
réapprenne à tisser des liens avec avec
ces personnes pas forcément le premier
vice président de la collectivité a
rappelé la volonté du département de
continuer à mettre en place des
dispositifs pour venir en aide au plus
grand nombre de réunionnais ne pense pas
pouvoir éradiquer la misère
tout seul on pourra pas y arriver mais
notre rôle c'est d'aider du mieux que
nous pouvons toutes ces familles en
grande difficulté pour cela nous avons
bien sûr de travailleurs sociaux sur le
terrain qui font un travail remarquable
auprès de ces familles et au delà des
travailleurs sociaux nous avons aussi
des partenaires les associations comme
la banque alimentaire des mascareignes
et d'autres encore qui par leur
implication sur le terrain est bien être
collectivité départementale à mener des
politiques sociales pour lutter contre
la pauvreté
parmi les personnalités présentes ayant
participé à la fabrication de cette
exposition historiens géographes mario
serviable et qui nous livre sa vision de
la pauvreté
c'est la grande pauvreté vous savez que
la france avec 192 pays ont signé en
2015 ce que l'on appelle les objectifs
du millénaire c'est à dire l'éradication
de la grande pauvreté en 2030
moi je pose la question tout bêtement
pour arriver à éradiquer en 2030
quand est ce que l'on commence à
découvrir donc
cette exposition la production de la
pauvreté dans le monde en tapis mendiant
pour un monde intolérable une exposition
d'éducation populaire proposé dans
l'espace d'accueil de la bibliothèque
départementale